georgia y pensilvania cómo está el
panorama de la situación en georgia hay
que entenderla a partir de los centros
urbanos más grandes atlanta y sus
suburbios aún tienen muchos votos que
contar lo mismo que la ciudad de augusta
y en menor medida columbus esos tres
centros van a ser neurálgicos para
determinar si el candidato joe biden
tiene la posibilidad de rebasar lo que
ha hecho de manera muy positiva el
presidente donald trump ha venido
incrementando su participación en ese
estado y por el otro lado el estado de
pensilvania es un estado histórico y
fundamental es el históricamente es
importante por la industria siderúrgica
por la industria petrolera y en los
últimos años despunta con mucha fuerza
el fracking de tal forma que el discurso
basado en una revolución energética de
you by then en ocasiones no sentaba muy
bien asimismo hay que tener en cuenta
que cuando el presidente
donald trump se retiró del tratado de
parís fue a la ciudad de pittsburgh
emblemática por la industria del acero y
dijo es por ustedes es por los trabajos
que se están perdiendo respecto a china
que he decidido sacar a los eeuu
de ese importante acuerdo medioambiental
entonces ha hecho que en los últimos
años los demócratas que habían ganado
hasta el 2016 seis elecciones
consecutivas en el estado de pensilvania
hayan perdido esa importante plaza
hillary lo hizo particularmente mal hace
cuatro años disminuyó la votación total
que había tenido anteriormente barack
obama en el estado y ha confiado en el
presidente demócrata pero con hillary
clinton esa situación cambió
dramáticamente ha cambiado también la
composición hasta hace aproximadamente
20 o 25 años eran trabajadores
sindicalizados unión izados y la
transformación económica que ha vivido
ha hecho que en los últimos años pierdan
mucho peso
el trabajador blue colash es decir esa
persona que no tiene título
universitario pero que sin duda alguna
era importante en el entorno los centros
más importantes ya los hemos mencionado
en filadelfia pittsburgh en menor medida
scranton donde nació el candidato yo
bailo para ver qué hay del estado de
nevada que está completamente blindado
en este momento no tenemos ni
de una posible proyección contaron unos
votos hasta un punto dieron a conocer
hasta un punto los resultados y la
autoridad electoral allí dijo no vamos a
dar sino un resultado final en las
próximas 24 horas y allí hay una
proyección y es difícil saber que puede
decir entonces nevada en esta elección
en las últimas elecciones también ha
favorecido al partido demócrata los
centros más los centros urbanos más
importantes son los que van a determinar
la contienda y el porcentaje escrutado
todavía da un margen de maniobra para
que eventualmente un muy buen resultado
del candidato del presidente donald
trump acercará y pusiera más difícil la
balanza en ese estado sin embargo la
tendencia por la influencia de
california es que se vea favorecido por
a
favor mejor del partido demócrata con lo
cual yo voy de llegaría al mágico número
de 270 del cual hemos hablado que
tendría la posibilidad de conformar el
colegio electoral sin embargo también es
cierto que debido a la impugnación
especialmente en los estados del norte
puede que sea difícil de determinar con
precisión en este momento
el rumbo que va a tomar la elección del
estado claro entonces para yo vaivenes
nevada en este momento en este momento
sin momento lo es
muchas gracias rafael por este análisis
para nuestra audiencia aquí en france 24